all right everybody it's may 25th 2022
i'm dave rubin this is the reuben report
direct message as always we are live
streaming on rumble youtube
and blaze tv um we're gonna do something
a little bit different today in light of
the uvalde school shooting in texas
yesterday um you know i always do this
show basically unscripted we have a we
have a sort of loose outline
that we put together in the morning and
obviously we we have certain clips that
we want to throw to
but i don't write out the script
whatever i do on this show is john kind
of just coming out of my brain as it's
happening for better or worse
um but you know we saw the news of this
shooting yesterday afternoon and
immediately like everybody else
i jumped on twitter and you start seeing
stuff and all all you see basically
uh is fighting and endless fighting and
not only fighting but everyone going to
their political partisan side um trying
to own everybody else
people saying you know this should be
blamed on this person or this group or
this political party i mean it was just
it's just like the worst of everything
right and one of the things that
i'm so proud of that i i mention all the
time is that you know especially after
being on tour over the last couple weeks
is that the nicest thing that people say
to me is the thing that people usually
say to me it's the thing that people say
to me most often which is that i've
helped people stay sane over the last
couple years and if you've stayed
roughly sane you know approximately
saying over the last two years like
you've done pretty good right and uh
so i was trying to think how do we do a
show today first off there's other
things going on in the world right like
there's another shooting it's another
shooting every day there seems to be
another shooting uh there's another
disaster here or a war there or we got
problems with the economy or just like
the endless stuff right that is
constantly happening so how do we do the
show do i just do a quick segment on
this and say there was a shooting and
here's what happened and let's move on
because we know there'll be a shooting
next week
and let's talk about you know what silly
thing happened at the white house press
conference or what it bite and stumble
over or whatever else do we do that
or do we try to do something a little
bit different because as i was watching
everyone and i mean everybody across the
aisle so this is not something i'm going
to put solely on the beat of the lefties
who i'm usually criticizing it was
everybody everybody you know
let's this is about we need more guns we
need less guns i blame the republicans i
bring i blame the democrats all of the
stuff so i was really trying to think
like how do i do this in any kind of
sensible way so we're going to do
something completely different than
normal today there's no video on the
show today uh there is no
outline whatsoever other than i'm going
to just give you some basic information
on what happened yesterday but this is
an extraordinary tragedy and i get it
all of these shootings are incredible
tragedies right the idea that someone
shows up to work shows up to school
whatever and and gets shot like you send
your kids i mean in this case
i think the one the reason that this
one's feeling like particularly
uh awful
is you know we see these in high schools
we see these in junior high schools this
is elementary school it doesn't make it
worse at some level right but like it
does in another way and then yesterday i
was also thinking it's like we're about
to have kids and i was thinking about
these parents these parents you send
your five-year-old your six-year-old off
to school
and that's it and that's it so i thought
well what can i do today to not add to
the craziness is there anything i can do
today so i don't know that i can do
anything to not add to the craziness but
i am going to try
uh and i also try to do something that i
consistently try to do here which is
what can we do actually not to just sort
of address what's going on here um but
also figure out what what is a plan of
action so we can get out of this because
i think really what's happening
uh is that we're all sort of in this
slow descent to hell together right so
we we kind of pick up on these nice
moments and i i try to focus on the
night's moments and you know we've had
some wins lately i don't want to get
into all the political stuff but you
know about the political winds
but we seemingly are just slowly
going to some place worse we're slowly
just giving away the freedom and the joy
and the incredible culture that we had
in this country we're just letting it go
and we're all part of it and i would
include myself in that i try to do a
little bit better i sometimes fail at it
but everyone everyone we're all a piece
of it you watching are a piece of it
everyone's a piece of it i suspect if
you're watching it this you're probably
not quite as uh guilty when it comes to
some of the destruction right and you're
probably doing the best you can for the
most part in and how do we reverse this
um but we're all kind of guilty so it
does seem like it's like when kids we
have 18 kids at least
are now killed
and it's like what are we all doing
there's not even a there's barely a
moment online and maybe this is because
of what social media has done to us the
speed at which we get information and
can share information and the dopamine
desire to get clicks and own our
political opponents and again it's on
both sides so you know the guy on the
right can own the libtard and the
libtard can own the guy on the right and
the rest of that stuff but it's we're
just all constantly doing something that
is just
bringing us close to that abyss and i
suspect that when we when we get
to whatever that abyss is to the bottom
of the abyss is there a bottom of the
abyss i think we'll all go man
remember the good old days so i'm going
to try to clean some of that up uh here
so that's what we're going to be doing
today i will give you a little bit of
information specifically about the
shooting
and then we'll uh then we'll go from
there so i don't know if this is going
to be a 12-minute show or a hour and a
half show uh but bear with me and let's
see if we can make some sense at any of
this uh real quick before we get to that
i want to talk to you guys about policy
genius you know if someone is relying on
you financially a child a parent or even
a business partner life insurance is
going to give you a lot of peace of mind
it's important to know that they have a
financial cushion if something ever
happens to you policy genius is your one
stop shop to find the insurance you need
at the right price and you can head over
to policygenius.com
reuben home to get started in minutes
you'll be able to compare personalized
quotes from top companies to find your
lowest price you could save 50 percent
or more on life insurance by comparing
quotes with policy genius policy genius
doesn't add extra fees doesn't sell your
info to third parties and they have
thousands of five star reviews across
google and trustpilot they have options
that offer coverage in as little as a
week and let you avoid unnecessary
medical exams since 2014 policy genius
has helped over 30 million people shop
for insurance and has placed over 150
billion in coverage policy genius works
for you not the insurance companies so
get started today head over to
policygenius.com
reubenhome to get your free life
insurance quotes and see how much you
could save
okay so let's uh just get into the
specifics of what happened yesterday
when we were sourcing this i thought all
right why don't we actually try to go to
a place that i wouldn't normally source
from because i'm going to try to do this
as a politically as possible and just
give you the facts
so we have some information on what
happened yesterday in texas from the new
york times a gunman killed at least 19
children and two adults on tuesday in a
rural texas elementary school a state
police official said in the deadliest
american school shooting since the
massacre at sandy hook elementary a
decade ago
the slayings took place just before noon
at robb elementary school where second
through fourth graders in uvalde a small
city west of san antonio were preparing
to start summer break this week at least
one teacher was among the adults killed
and several other children were wounded
the gunman whom the authorities
identified as an eighteen-year-old man
who had attended a nearby high school
was armed with several weapons officials
said he also died at the scene they said
so i'm going to just talk for a moment
we have some images
from at the aftermath that i guess we
can get to as i'm talking for a second
or do we want to do the names first
yeah okay so uh we're just going to show
you a couple images here
and uh
what i wanted to say just sort of first
up top on this thing is that one of the
things that that social media has done
to us is i noticed you know when i first
saw the tweet that something had
happened and at first it sounded like
two people were shot it's just like oh
there's another shooting and you don't
know much and then the numbers started
to to jump and jump you know there's
this weird thing that happens online
where everybody everybody
starts thinking about politics first so
you you start forgetting that these are
human beings and that these are kids and
that you're looking at parents right
there who just lost uh their young
children who they had just sent to
school who were about to wrap up the
school year and enjoy the summer and all
that stuff and everyone goes to that
political place first right so you think
oh well depending on the skin color or
religion of the shooter i'll think this
or depending on the skin color or
religion of the victims i'll think this
or if we find out their manifesto said
they were right wing then i can blame
tucker carlson or if it said they were
left-wing i can blame bernie sanders or
all that stuff so there's this weird
moment when we hear about these things
first where we the the initial reaction
is not to sympathy it's not to empathy
and i noticed that i even noticed that
in myself like you hear of the shooting
and it's like there's barely like a
moment of of oh my god there's a human
tragedy here it's now like jumping on
well what happened and sort of how and
how are we gonna fight about it
i think that's a much bigger problem
than i can probably explain
right at this moment like the lack of
empathy that we're all sort of going
through right now or not that we're not
not that we're all going through we all
have it within us but it's being covered
up by the layer of social media that's
sitting on top of us right now and the
way that politics has become religion
politics has become everything so if
something horrific happens if 18
children are killed the immediate
reaction is not eva is barely a split
second barely an iota of empathy
it's how can i now use this for whatever
my political means are um so not all the
names of the students or teachers has
been have been released yet but i
thought we would just show you a few uh
to just humanize this a little bit irma
garcia her picture is not released yet
she was a fourth grade teacher who was
killed
there's eva morelles who is also a
fourth grade teacher uh uziyah garcia
who's a fourth grader
a mary jo garza a nine-year-old fourth
grader
uh xavier lopez 10 year old fourth
grader
uh got a couple more annabella guadalupe
age 10 4th grader elijah cruz torres
another 10 year old fourth grader
they're going to be more names released
you know apparently they haven't even
fully
figured out exactly what's what here
but i think it's just important i think
it's just important and by the way
before some people jump on me and i have
no doubt that they will i know that
there was also a horrific shooting about
a week and a half ago in buffalo i was
not here i was not in studio we
obviously would have covered it um
you know so i'm just putting it out
there
so look i'm not going to name the
shooter right i'm not going to name the
shooter because many times the shooters
and it's irrelevant to me what his
ethnicity is and in some ways it's
not in always but in some ways it's
irrelevant to me what his political
ideology was if he even had a political
ideology he happened to be an 18 year
old i can tell you that
uh i'm not going to tell you his
immigration status or any of those
things
it's not that they don't completely
matter but maybe they don't matter just
this very second okay um but everyone
wanted to jump to oh it's this person
and he's this skin color and how did he
feel about immigration and
and all of these things so i'm not going
to tell you his name i think that's the
most important part because many of
these shooters we find out later you
know they have all sorts of
psychological problems right they have
all sorts of mental problems and we
rarely talk about that right we don't
talk about mental health in this country
um and perhaps what we're all dealing
with is a collective mental health
problem right we've unearthed something
about all of us that the algorithms have
weaponized against us and it has led to
a mass collective mental health problem
but we do know that many of these
shooters they want to be famous
you know they feel so lost they feel so
irrelevant for whatever reason
it might be
that they want to be known as someone
and you may remember years ago after the
boston
massacre
when rolling stone put the shooter on
the cover and tried to make him kind of
look sexy and like he should be
appealing and uh and it was absolutely
horrific absolutely horrific that they
did that it instigates more of this so
we can all point figures everywhere we
can point fingers at ourselves we can
point figures that the way the media
looks at this at the way we we worship
and and
it's not that we're worshiping the
murderers but the way we react
to all of this the way we we care about
some things and don't care about other
things
for example right now there are plenty
of people
all over the internet screaming about
all about this shooting and they should
be
they should be and we can have a
discussion uh about guns and we can have
a discussion about school safety and we
can have that mental health discussion
and all of those things um but the same
people who will be screaming about all
of those things and a lot of those
things
they're not going to mention that 48
people were shot in chicago this past
weekend 48 were shot in chicago six of
them fatally
that's not going to be on cnn it's not
going to be on msnbc it's not going to
be in the washington post or the new
york times
that's just one of the inconsistencies
that we have so
it's like oh when a certain set of
people shoot a certain set of people we
don't really care
and when they do it in a city like
chicago which has the most stringent gun
laws we don't really care because that's
really hard to grapple with that it's
generally black people shooting black
people in a place that there's a lot of
gun laws that one's hard to grapple with
if we can take one where it's a white
guy shooting a black guy or whatever we
we do that whole politization and we
have to back up from that we have to
stop thinking about everything is just
about policy that everything is just
about politics you know i did watch a
little bit i did not watch all of it i
watched some of biden's speech last
night now look
i don't agree with joe biden i don't
think he should be president of the
united states i don't think he's
mentally fit to be president of the
united states i think his policies have
been horrible i think that the democrats
are actually at this point intentionally
destroying the country i really believe
that at this point um
however i was hoping when i was watching
the speech last night
that he could try to do something a
little better than politics right that
whoever writes his speech and tells him
what to say could do something a little
bit better and not blame the gun lobby
and not blame uh the republicans and all
of this stuff and he couldn't it was a
absolutely horrific speech i'm not you
know we discussed okay maybe we could
show some clips of it i'm not going to
show you the clips of it today
um maybe we'll show it tomorrow i
thought today has to be about something
else but it's like we have these brief
moments
these brief moments where we can all
me you biden
everybody we can all be a little bit
better than ourselves and he chose not
to
he chose not to he chose to make it
political oh this is about the people
that you know are for guns and it's just
not that simple it's just not that
simple it's just not that simple as
blaming the nra the nra which
basically
protects
the second amendment and by the way the
second amendment the right to bear arms
that protects the first amendment
and in the last two years with all of
the horrible stuff that governments not
only in america but all over the world
did
i think a lot of people are very happy
that the second amendment exists and
there's a lot of new gun owners because
of that myself included because of the
overreach of government and realizing
that law enforcement can't do everything
there's also a certain set of people
that think if we just had more laws
if we just had more regulations you
could stop all the bad things from
happening and i think it's a fundamental
misunderstanding of what being human is
we can create every law we can have
every regulation
and bad people are still going to do bad
things bad people generally don't listen
to laws bad people generally don't
listen to regulations bad people if they
want to find weapons they will find
weapons and if they can't kill you with
a gun
they can find other ways to kill you
and we can get good people to behave in
certain ways we can maybe get a bulk of
people to behave in certain ways but
most people aren't killing other people
we're talking about fringe people and we
can talk about background checks and by
the way we do have background checks and
we can perhaps talk about little
loopholes that maybe sort of still exist
but none of it is as simple as the media
portrays it is if we just had sensible
gun laws we do basically have sensible
gun laws bad people are going to figure
out a way to get things from what i
understand then i don't want to get too
into the specifics of this kid but he
just turned 18 he got the guns
he got the guns legally from what i
understand there was a background check
involved this is some of this is
unfolding right now so don't hold me to
all of this do a little research on your
own
um but the point is that you can have
all these checks and a a person can pass
checks and still do bad things
you know we can we can do talk about all
of these things but if we're immediately
going to say oh
something horrific happened i'm not even
going to take a moment to think about
those kids those faces that we just
showed you and that's
barely ten per i don't know it's
whatever it is it's two percent of it's
just a small percentage of of the kids
that were killed maybe more of a will
you know are in the hospital right now
it's like if we're just going to jump to
oh and this just proves that i'm right
politically then we got a big problem
and i think what we're all seeing right
now is we're going from one crisis to
another whether it's a covid crisis to
an abortion crisis to an economic crisis
to a shooting crisis
and every time we have a little reprieve
and we have these little moments there
are these little brief moments where
we'll have like two weeks where
everything you know there was one uh
what was it last summer remember last
summer around june when coveted things
started opening up and people started
feeling a little bit better and there
was this feeling like oh things are
going to be okay and then suddenly kovid
came back
and here it's like we had we had a good
month about a month ago remember there
were a bunch of wins in sort of the
culture i don't mean to make this about
politics but culturally there were a
couple good wins the masks came off
because of judge mizell there was the
elon and the twitter thing there was all
the good stuff that that ron desantis is
doing here in florida that's being
exported throughout the country there
were winds and then suddenly this roe v
wade came thing came in and we all
started hating each other again and then
in the last week that seemed to die down
that seemed to die down a little bit and
now this and now we'll start hating each
other again and it's like i don't know
are we all being played by the system is
are we all just in some truman-like show
that we're we're just being manipulated
by forces that we can't quite see uh
perhaps but
we have to figure out some ways about
out of it we really do
and i think the only way out of it is
figuring out how you are going to react
to it so what why does any of this
matter what is how is this all related
and what what do we do
what do we do all right so i'm going to
try to give you some answers in just a
sec i just want to talk to you about
alto ira for just a moment uh
cryptocurrency may represent the future
of money it's one of the most exciting
investment opportunities around for some
time but what about taxes you got to pay
taxes people with an alto crypto ira you
can trade crypto like bitcoin and avoid
or defer the taxes there are multiple
ways to fund your account you can make a
cash contribution transfer cash from an
existing ira or roll over an old 401k
you can trade all you want without the
tax headache and you can create an
account in just a few minutes ready to
take your investments to the next level
diversify like the pros and trade
without the tax headaches open an alto
crypto ira with just as little as ten
dollars just go to alto ira.com ruben
that's a l t o i r a dot com slash rubin
start investing in cryptocurrency today
alto ira.com
reuben okay so i want to be very clear
one of the reasons that we wanted to do
no assets today so i'm not showing you
any video i'm not showing you any
pictures i'm not showing you any tweets
any of that stuff is because it was it
was actually making me crazy
it wasn't just the people i don't like
right it's always easy to find tweets
from the ridiculous lefty politicians
and the blue check people that i don't
like i could do that all day for the
rest of my life and we can laugh at them
and we can make fun of them and i can
say silly things about them
i can do that all the time even the
people i like immediately jumping to
politics right and i just didn't want to
show you any of that i will say we are
going to cloak do a cold close today
it's about a three minute video that we
found about the how precious america is
and what we're sort of seemingly giving
away at the moment that i thought would
be a nice way to end this but beyond
that we're not showing you any elements
um but also i think it's also an
inappropriate time to do it right
try to imagine if you're one of the
parents of these kids think about so
there are 18 or 19 kids that are dead
right now
again they were alive yesterday at this
time
they are dead right now
there are now thousands of people that
are mourning directly
right if you extrapolate that from
parents and aunts and uncles and friends
and family and local community and
church and synagogue and all of those
things where you're going to go with all
of that thousands of people are in
direct mourning not just the distance of
a guy in another state talking about
this
so i didn't want to just dive into oh
look what this idiot said and look what
that [ __ ] said and the rest of it um
but also it's not going to solve
anything
it's not going to solve anything i can
sit here and tell you that i'm a strong
defender of the second i'm probably
stronger than i've ever been in my
entire life i can tell you that i for
the most part don't think that this is a
gun problem
if every single person in america had a
gun
99.9 percent of people would not run
around shooting people right it's far
more it's what you do with the weapon
and why you do it it's whether you have
a mental health problem or a perceived
grievance or whatever it might be right
so we have to that's really what we
should be talking about why do people do
this not what did they do it with
because we already have laws around how
they can can or cannot get these weapons
so we have to talk about something
that's within all of us
um so it's not
it's not just the thing is that they're
going to distract you right now we're
now going to deal with two weeks of a
fight about guns and that's not really
what this is about
it's not what it's about i want you a
person watching this right now think
about it if you might have guns
you might not but do you think about
randomly going around and shooting
people whether they're at a church or a
school or anywhere else do you get upset
with people in your life yeah you
probably do do you have some people you
really don't like yeah you probably do
have you had it with the other side
politically yeah you probably do but
what causes you not to run around and
shoot people
what causes you not to do it
it's because
you're sane you're mentally healthy
you have you have figured out that
there's some value in life in your life
and in other people's lives that's
really the issue but we're not going to
talk about that instead there's going to
be a mass move to destroy the nra to
blame they're going to try to blame
trump they're going to try to blame ted
cruz and all the republicans and
everything else
and and what we should be talking about
here
is
how do you have a healthy mind
in this insanity how do you have a
healthy mind i think one way you can
have a healthy mind this is one of the
things that i write about and don't burn
this country is that you have to have a
healthy community
and what i mean by community is not a
community based on your skin color or
even your sexuality or your gender
but a community based on shared values
that's what we have to return to that
that's why the culture thing that's why
we've been in this culture war right
what what war have we really been in
america in the last 10 years it's been a
culture war there's a political war
meaning there's a political policy war
we're obsessed with politics all the
time okay the republicans voted this way
for this and the democrats voted this
way and if it wasn't for manchin doing
this then this would have happened and
all those things but that's secondary
that's still below what's really going
on here
there is there is a culture
that we have to have in in this country
and in every country but it starts with
you it starts with you saying all right
what kind of person am i going to be and
i do not sit here as the perfect person
i make mistakes
um i sometimes act in ways that i wish i
would not uh i can be short-tempered
occasionally not that often but i can be
whatever it might be right
we need to talk about the culture what
is leading us to a place where people
would do these things and again
even in a system where where we do
everything we can to teach all the right
things
whatever that means i mean i don't think
it can be done federally we're a country
of 350 million people from every walk of
life from every corner of earth i don't
think that the the federal government as
one unit above us can teach us all of
the right things right you and your
family have to teach your kids to be
better people you have to teach them
what meaning is and if you believe in
god or what wherever you get
your ethics from and all of those things
but it needs to be done locally first
it needs that's really what it needs to
be there there's no we're all we're
gonna focus now on is what can the
government do to stop these things from
happening and it's like pretty much
nothing that would be my
that would be my take on it uh joe biden
is not gonna save you he's not and guess
what if donald trump was president right
now and this had happened donald trump
was not going to save you i think the
only thing that can save you is figuring
out what works at your local community
now what what that might mean i can tell
you this that
growing up we would when we would go to
temple on the high holidays so we would
go to temple on rosh hashanah yom kippur
whatever the holidays might be
at the temple that i grew up in a nice
area in suburban long island we always
had armed security there there was
always armed security there and we'd
have to go in and pass armed security
and when you're a kid and you walk by
you kind of you don't really think about
it too much but there's like this moment
of like why are these guys you know in
in uniforms with guns why are they
standing here and then there's this
thing well there's a certain amount of
people uh that would like to just
randomly kill jews it's just a thing and
it exists and it's existed for a long
time so what you can do as a community i
have no doubt that uh the people
at the synagogue my dad was somewhat
involved with it uh would have to make
sure okay we have to make sure that we
have security guards here so that we can
pray and worship and come together uh in
a in a safe manner right we have to be
able to do that
um and i think everyone's gonna have to
think about that a little bit
differently like if your answer is take
away all the guns again the bad guys are
gonna still have guns so maybe we have
to talk about at the local level at the
real local level like
what are the entry points to schools
um do we have to have an armed guard at
every school and does that armed guard
really have to be a member of the
community not just some guy you're
paying 12 bucks to stand there and not
really pay attention
does it need to be parents that come
together
we have to figure out the mental health
situation and and does the does all the
funding for mental health have to come
from the government does the government
do anything you know i remember when i
was in los angeles there would always be
signs everywhere about like los angeles
mental health and call this number and i
always thought like who in their right
mind like i guess there's a little irony
there would be thinking man i have
mental problems i'm going to call los
angeles government and they're going to
help me it's like that's not really
where the help is going to come from we
gotta nip it in the bud before it gets
to that point and what that means is
it's family it's friends it's your
freaking neighbors you know i talk about
it all the time since i've moved to
florida i've really tried
when i walk my dog i do it every day
including this morning walking clyde um
i try to say hello to my neighbors when
they walk by you know everyone always
they let dogs say hi and who's this oh
this is clyde who's this oh this is
bernard okay they say hi and it's like i
try to say hey by the way i'm dave how
you doing we just moved in and try to
know people and if you maybe know a few
more people in your community then maybe
your community will be a little safer
because maybe if a shady guy
shows up at night and is lurking around
maybe somebody's going to make a call on
their behalf and on your behalf so that
is the only way we will get out of this
like actually
not doing this all day and staring at
this thing but reminding each other that
we're humans i know it's cliche i don't
think i'm reinventing the wheel here but
but
man a little bit of a pause might be
good
um because when something like this
happens we can the easy answer and where
i can sense it you can feel it right now
what we're just going to do is going to
get more divided so let's say we're a
country and we're a whole unit right or
a whole unit we're an apple
and it doesn't mean that that apple is
the most perfect apple but it's a pretty
damn good apple
right
now the choice is something bad happened
so the apple now got split in half and
some of us are going to go this way some
of us are going this way do we want to
just keep chopping it up keep chopping
it up keep chopping it up and then we'll
just sort of have nothing we'll just
have some mush
that's what we can do but
i think there is another way and that is
relying on one another that's that's
really all we can do and i don't know
exactly what that means but i do know
that again from being on tour i know
that's what people are looking for
i know that's why people when they did
the meet and greets and they give me the
hug and they smile and thank me it's
like
there was something you're doing dave
that that is sort of what i was looking
for and the only reason i'm doing this
is because it's kind of what i was
looking for and i was like well nobody
else is doing it i guess i'll do it um
and that's why i wanted to approach the
show this way
today
and not make it purely political to the
best of my ability um and that's also
why we have to stop
obsessing over government and politics
and it's ironic i suppose for a guy that
hosts a political show to say that so
what would that really look like well
we'd have to get back to a little bit of
old america that's a little bit of
knowing our neighbors that's a little
bit of being more involved in our
communities i we have a a
flea market here on sundays that's all
local vendors we try to go on every
sunday and we bring clyde and we try to
buy from the local vendors and i try to
talk to a few of the people around there
like it's something it's something
that's not this endless chaos
um you know knowing that you could rely
on your neighbor for something right not
just like oh i'm out of butter
but like you know in a pinch you know if
you if there was an emergency and you
know you had to go away for a weekend
that your neighbor would look after your
house or look after your dog or whatever
it is
um so it's your community it's your
faith it's it's it's your family it's
all of those things which we all do
inconsistently and we take for granted
and all of that um but out of that out
of that base
is what will spring something stronger
so that when the bad things happen and
the bad things are going to happen
whether it's a democrat that's president
or a republican that's president whether
we have stricter gun laws or less strict
gun laws whether whether abortion is
legal in all 50 states or it's not or
it's kicked back to states whatever the
issue of the day is if your community is
strong if you if you stand up straight
with your shoulders back if you try to
put truth into the world then you're not
going to be every time the wave hits you
it's not going to completely obliterate
you the house will still be standing and
it might be dinged up a little bit but
the foundation will be strong i think
that's the only way we get out of this
thing i think that is the only thing the
only way we get out of this thing um so
look
is it obvious that my general position
would be that the answer is not to take
away guns yes
is it obvious that my general position
would be we should be defending our
schools more with guns yeah it is
i don't think that's exactly uh for
today so how can we act today uh before
before we wrap up
let's just try to do a little bit better
let's just try to do a little bit better
um
it doesn't matter who's in charge
they're not here to take care of you
you're here to take care of yourself be
a little bit more self-reliant uh maybe
say hi to your neighbor today maybe
don't spend all day on this thing i'm
not doing social media today i'll jump
on locals maybe i'll do a live chat on
locals later just to talk to you guys
but don't spend all day on this thing
today uh don't spell spend all day on
zoom and on social media and postmates
and doordash and uber and amazon and
netflix for a week
maybe try to get off this every now and
again maybe on the weekends you know i
do my off the grid august which for me
this year is going to be quite different
because
we're we're going to have a baby and
that also maybe is why i'm a little more
[Music]
a little more emotional over this
because i just see in these kids
it's like man i'm about to enter
parenthood and i just can't even imagine
how these these parents are feeling
right now
um
but
control this thing a little bit more
these these things that are removing us
from the real world these things that
were promised to make us more social
that make us more anti-social
but i think maybe if we try to do all
that
that will uh that will do a little
something so i hope this provided a
little bit of value for you i know it's
a little bit different than we normally
would do we'll we'll get back to the to
the normal thing tomorrow obviously the
story in and of itself is not going to
go anywhere there's going to be all
sorts of political repercussions and
it's not to say that those things aren't
important we should always be fighting
for what we believe in politically you
should always be voting for people who
you think can
can sort of direct the ship a little bit
more in the direction that you want to
go in of course
but i also think it's okay to
occasionally
um
step back from that and i think that's
important so i was thinking before like
how can we end this right maybe maybe
not me how can we end this right and uh
of course immediately
america and you know i've been playing
some of these ronald reagan clips so
here's the three minutes of ronald
reagan when he was president talking
about how precious america is maybe
think about that a little bit and we'll
do this again tomorrow thanks everyone
this national feeling is good
but it won't count for much and it won't
last
unless it's grounded in thoughtfulness
and knowledge
and informed patriotism is what we want
and are we doing a good enough job
teaching our children what america is
and what she represents in the long
history of the world
those of us who are over 35 or so years
of
age grew up in a different america
we were taught very directly what it
means to be an american and we absorbed
almost in the air a love of country and
an appreciation of its institutions
if you didn't get these things from your
family you got them from the
neighborhood
from the father down the street who
fought in korea of the family who lost
someone at anzio
or you can get a sense of patriotism
from school
and if all else failed
you could get a sense of patriotism from
the popular culture
the movies celebrated democratic values
and implicitly reinforced the idea that
america was special
tv was like that too through the mid 60s
but now we're about to enter the 90s
and some things have changed
younger parents aren't sure that an
unambivalent appreciation of america is
the right thing to teach modern children
and as for those who create the popular
culture
well-grounded patriotism is no longer
the style
our spirit is back but we haven't
reinstitutionalized it
we've got to do a better job of getting
across that america is freedom
freedom of speech
freedom of religion
freedom of enterprise and freedom is
special and rare
it's fragile
it needs production
so we've got to teach history based not
on what's in fashion
but what's important
why the pilgrims came here who jimmy
doolittle was and what those 30 seconds
over tokyo meant
you know four years ago on the 40th
anniversary of d-day
i read a letter from a young woman
writing to her late father who had
fought on omaha beach
her name was lisa zanetta hen
and she said
we will always remember
we will never forget what the boys of
normandy did
well let's help her keep her word
if we forget what we did
we won't know who we are
i'm warning of an eradication of that of
the american memory that could result
ultimately in an erosion of the american
spirit
let's start with some basics more
attention to american history and a
greater emphasis on civic ritual
and let me offer lesson number one about
america
all great change in america begins at
the dinner table
so tonight in the kitchen
i hope the talking begins
and children if your parents haven't
been teaching you what it means to be an
american
let them know
and nail them on it
that would be a very american thing to
do